a los videojuegos amamos los videojuegos
esos pequeños discos que con el juego
correcto no hacen olvidarnos de todas
nuestras responsabilidades en la vida
real mientras disfrutamos de fantasías
virtuales como destrozar cientos de
enemigos al tiempo o convertirnos en un
ganso si las posibilidades son infinitas
en los videojuegos pero más allá de
hacer simples discos existen ediciones
especiales de algunos videojuegos que
contienen mucho más contenido las
ediciones de coleccionista que son
básicamente ediciones especiales de un
mismo videojuego que son más costosas
pero que contienen merchandising algunos
coleccionables de lcd o cualquier clase
de objetos que pueden llamar la atención
de los jugadores
no obviamente a mí me encantan las
direcciones de coleccionista pero sí
como algunas ediciones que hablen
totalmente la pena hay otras que son una
[ __ ] y en casos más raros existen
ediciones de coleccionista que más allá
de ser malas son bastante
vamos que son bastante extrañas algunas
hasta perturbadoras ya verán de qué
hablo
[Música]
de vuelta en 2011 clases fue uno de los
juegos más asombrosos visualmente del
momento vamos a estreno hace ocho años y
aún así viene incluso para los
estándares de ahora tal era el avance
gráfico de crisis que sus creadores
decidieron poner a la venta la máxima
graphics edición una edición de
coleccionista que contenía el juego como
tal una camiseta con diseño del juego un
póster y lo más llamativo trae una
tarjeta gráfica incluida la gtx 560 t y
que acumular las tarjetas gráficas más
punteras en aquel momento y una lo
suficientemente potente como para correr
países 2 en su configuración gráfica más
alta además de venir con un diseño
personalizado del videojuego
tal vez reich 2 no fue el éxito que
bethesda esperaba ojo que niego que se
llama el juego solo que no pegó tanto a
mí me encantó su despliegue de luces
colores y violencia pero a pesar de no
ser el éxito esperado lo que sí hicieron
fue sorprender a aquellos suertudos que
se hicieron con una de sus extravagantes
versiones del juego la edición
coleccionista de rage 2 contenían lo
básico un póster contenido descargable
dlc de esas cosas el juego en una caja
metálica y una cabeza cercenada de un
mutante vamos genial si quieres espero
te imagines tarde-noche en tu casa y ven
algo así y que de repente te hable
[Música]
canta
cualquier persona que haya jugado acá
swing de saber ya de por sí que el juego
es raro como el sol ojos tienes a un
tipo en boxers con problemas amorosos
windows peldaños hablando con ovejas y
escapando de monstruos sí qué [ __ ]
sabes pero dentro de todo es un buen
juego lo curioso es lo que sus creadores
decidieron poner en su edición de
coleccionista comenzando con el juego su
banda sonora un libro de arte conceptual
una camiseta una almohada con la imagen
de qazvin
y para rematar unos boxers idénticos a
los que usa el protagonista del juego a
la mayor parte del tiempo
todo esto empacado una caja bastante
peculiar decorada como una caja de pizza
empecemos por el hecho de que cualquier
juego que incluyen los boxers porque fue
demasiado lejos además de incluir una
almohada con una imagen sugestiva de una
de las mujeres del juego parece que los
que hicieron esta decisión sabían a qué
público iba dirigido su juego
de 45 años con sus padres
leandro live es un juego de lucha un
poco el estilo tekken que junta
personajes con un estilo muy asiático
porque algunos personajes invitados como
ryu hayabusa y algunas personas de ninja
gaiden es un juego de pelea bastante
bueno y al parecer
un éxito considerable tomando en cuenta
que ya a día de hoy cuenta con seis
entregas pero honestamente no sé qué
[ __ ] pasó por la mente y sus creadores
porque después de un tiempo y de ver el
éxito que está teniendo la saga
naturalmente decidieron sacar secuelas
del juego pero no muy dirigidas al
género de lucha que tenía el juego sino
que decidieron hacer juegos con temática
deportiva en donde los protagonistas del
juego de lucha se para se harían en poca
ropa por la playa
[Aplausos]
no se nota que es asiático el juego
y vamos como si ya no fuera lo bastante
raro con los amigos que emiten algunas
luchadoras al golpear como si cada golpe
les dirá placer del bueno
llega este juego que se trata
básicamente solo de los ojos de las
luchadoras y lo empeora todo o la cep
anto los que compran alguno de estos
juegos que tienen virgen marcado la
frente para rematar el tercer juego de
esta peculiar saga fin yo con una
edición de coleccionista de contenía un
mouse para donde los pechos de una de
las chicas del juego funcionará como una
almohadilla para tu afortunada muñeca de
board
y unos postres sugestivos para
colocarlos en la ducha
el nuevo juego de hideo kojima de
standing es ya de por sí bastante raro
enigmático de que nos dejó en duda por
mucho tiempo sobre que va a tratar y
básicamente no sabíamos un [ __ ] del
juego pero nosotros en un juego
extraordinario único en su clase pero es
de que ese reloj todo lo que su edición
coleccionista iba a contenerse [ __ ] aún
más extraño a ver la agresión venía
dentro de un maletín conteniendo un
llavero una caja metálica con el juego
contenido exclusivo del juego como tlc
de objetos exclusivos que se podrán
utilizar en el mismo juego junto con
álbum de la banda sonora el juego y un
bebé si tal como aparece en el juego
tendremos una réplica los llamados bebé
que se utilizan en dead son como una
especie de fuente energía o no sé que
una conexión con el mundo los muertos al
base dentro de un contenedor no tendrá
alguna especie de líquido dentro con el
juego base pero sí que tendrá luces así
funcionan con una especie de lámpara
genial que no quisiera tener un bebé
encapsulado como lámpara adornando su
mesita de noche
claro que tener un bebé cápsula do es
bastante raro pero esto ya es otro nivel
verá el lifetime fue más allá con la
mercancía de zombies es una figura de un
zombi como un arte conceptual o alguna
cosa más normal eso fueron a lo grande
tal vez demasiado grande junto con un
juego en una caja metálica y de lcd es
contenido exclusivo del título venía
este torso a medio comer de una mujer en
bikini o nueva entiendan
ambas cosas por separado son geniales
pero juntas y sobre todo llevas de esta
manera y arrayán lo perturbador me
encanta todo el contenido zombies pero
esto es demasiado tanta fue la
controversia con esta figura que los
publicistas tuvieron que dar una
disculpa pública por tan alarmante
objeto
bueno desde este punto ya estamos en
otro tono bien light es otro juego de
zombies pero con innovadoras mecánicas
de parkour y exploración que dieron un
toque fresco al juego en lo personal es
uno de mis juegos de zombies favoritos
en serio si no lo probaste lo recomiendo
muchísimo pero su edición coleccionista
mi apocalipsis fue una total barbaridad
que es genial eso sí pero es demasiado
para cualquiera sabe el objetivo de esta
edición de coleccionista más que darte
la oportunidad de jugar un apocalipsis
zombie quiere que tú mismo lo vivas está
explicó la visión de mi apocalipsis por
un módico precio de más de 300 mil
dólares incluye dos juegos de audífonos
cuatro copias del juego un tour para ti
y tus amigos a las oficinas de los
desarrolladores 4 pañales de adulto unos
lentes de visión nocturna la opción de
poner tu rostro en el juego lecciones
profesionales de parkour una escultura
tamaño real de uno de los zombies del
juego que eso sí que mola y tu propio
refugio anti zombies
la verdad que está genial pero quién
estaría dispuesto a pagar casi 400 mil
dólares por todo esto
[Música]
el embarazo el milagro de la vida es
hermoso verdad bueno no a cuando sea en
el espectro de una mujer esquelética y
asesina filtre desde un gran paso con
esto es verdad que es un juego de terror
y si también es verdad que es genial
tener figuras que te recurren a tus
juegos favoritos pero en serio quieres
tener esto en tu cuarto la edición
coleccionista de phil 3 viene con un
contenido para el juego una caja
metálica con el mismo disco un cómic y
una figura de alma la principal
antagonista de la franquicia desnuda y
embarazada ahí se me olvidó mencionar
que su diente brilla en la oscuridad
centro grados el juego de mundo abierto
con el mismo estilo sandbox que gta de
hecho tengo que hacer la competencia en
entidad sólo que con un estilo más
atrevido mandando a [ __ ] toda la ética
en su juego
este estilo atrevido se nota con su
visión de coleccionista que cuesta tan
sólo un millón de dólares en serio no es
broma eso lo que cuesta por este precio
vas a conseguir lo siguiente
el juego un viaje el espacio una réplica
tamaño real del arma taser vista en el
juego una experiencia de rescate de
rehenes una cirugía plástica un día
entero entrenamiento para hacer espía un
asistente de compras para renovar su
guardarropas un vuelo a washington desde
y agua
una semana en un hotel lujoso de
washington dc y otra semana en otro
hotel de uruguay un toyota prius con un
año seguro y un lamborghini gallardo y
nuevamente todas estas cosas no están
para nada mal pero un millón de dólares
usuario
después de todo lo que hemos visto
llegamos a lo que yo considero la
edición de coleccionista más extraña y
lo que hasta la fecha como ya vimos unos
puestos atrás
diane like that to be por si una edición
de coleccionista algo exagerada es la
expansión de following fue un paso aún
más lejos ofreciendo esta monstruosidad
por el bajo y bajo precio de 10 millones
de dólares vas a recibir un papel
secundario una película aún no anunciada
en light clases de actuación profesional
sesiones de entrenamiento de parkour tu
propio tráiler para el set de rodaje de
la película una copia del guión sesión
de maquillaje y efectos especiales curso
de conducción tour de presentación de la
película 10 entradas vip y a la premier
4 copias de diane light con su expansión
the following y tendrás la oportunidad
de prestar tu voz al protagonista del
juego en una edición especial bajo la
exageración hecha a juego claro está que
no estoy del todo seguro que esto fue
hecho como una broma una estrategia
marketing dado que aún no se vendió
ninguna de estas ediciones pero en caso
de que sea legítimo 10 millones eso que
se pasaron un poco con esta edición pero
hoy si te gusta el tema de los zombies y
te sobran 10 millones de dólares por qué
no
[Música]
eso ha sido todo pero quién sabe tal vez
haya otras ediciones de coleccionista
extrañas rondando por ahí de las que yo
no tengo una idea así que si conoces de
otra edición extraña déjame en los
comentarios
y si eres un publicista y quieres que
alguien te hagan un boxing de un
producto o una edición de coleccionista
soy el indicado vamos a que no le gusta
que le cosas gratis
[Música]
ah